Jamie is too hot in here.
Turn the AC up,
Jamie.
Please look up.
See if anyone has.
Let's go champ.
Tattooed on their belly.
See if find that Janet men with a
crocodile scarring.
Jamie,
see if he could pull that up.
See I a plane crashes in Mexico with
tons of cocaine.
They overloaded their plane.
Jamie,
pull up some video of Al Jolson in
blackface.
So I tweeted something today that
somebody tweeted me or I read something
that somebody tweeted,
so I quoted it,
but it wasn't right.
God dammit.
That was pretty close that Donald trump
will be 70 years old and six days.
So it is seven months in,
six days.
Seven months.
Seven year olds,
70 years old.
Seven months in,
six days.
Almost seven year old years old.
Seven months and seven days when he
becomes the president.
And he won by 77 electoral votes from
seven electors.
Wow.
Happy seventh anniversary of the gre to
basically it pretty glow tomorrow.
Yeah.
How crazy is that?
That is crazy.
So a lot of sevens.
Why are you obsessed with seven?
It's like,
why is your shirt came from the.
Are One time we're talking about how we
were in a simulation theory and how
everything's made out of ones and Zeros
and I said something like,
I'm going to hack it.
I'm ready to start saying sevens or
some.
I can't even remember what it was,
but it's all from that.
So this is your shirt that has all
sevens.
It's.
Yeah,
it's made from sevens.
It is a whole.
It's just a bunch of different color
sevens.
Yeah.
To make the artwork.
And this sweatshirts the desk squad
seven slash 11 shirt
episode seven,
seven seven.
So I thought it had to be you because of
all the,
your seven references that you threw in
all throughout the years at number
haunts me.
So bad.
Why?
I don't know.
It just comes up so much now.
Okay,
sure.
I have a seven on my shirt.
Do you?
Uh,
I dunno,
I might.
I don't give a fuck.
How about that?
You gave a seven on your hat,
Brian.
A dumber pigeons to.
Well look,
I'll in their heads are mad if your head
was that little.
Yeah,
I guess,
but
I mean Zika babies grow up to be pretty
smart.
Nope,
we haven't had any.
That's true.
Actually.
It hasn't grown up.
I really.
I don't think so.
I mean,
not that I've ever heard of.
I just made that up.
I think there's actually adult Zika
babies.
I think so because I was thinking about
making Zika hats for Zika people,
so it makes it look like their heads are
bigger.
The whole key is to get somebody who
spars with you.
That's not trying to hurt you,
but it's just trying to grow with you
and learn.
That's so hard because egos get involved
late.
George would never hurt you.
What?
Boy?
George.
Who would never heard you?
Oh,
sorry.
All right.
That's it.
Where else we're going to go?
No,
that looks like he's fully hard to deck
guys.
Giant.
It's a giant Dick.
Come on son.
You know that Shit's real.
You want it to be real.
No,
I'm scared.
She that could just be.
Oh look,
he's got marijuana leaf tattooed right
above his dick.
Like,
what's that supposed to mean?
Yeah,
smoke it,
smoke it if he got it.
Hashtags he has on there.
How does body
will change your life drops,
Mike.
Restructure your day.
This dick
edges slick down.
This dick can file your nails.
This dick.
This tongue will make you late for work.
Wait,
this dick can be a best friend.
This dick console and bundles.
I'm not sure what that means.
If you can.
I'll eat a pussy.
Oh,
you can take the whole thing.
Can you not?
If you can only Hashtag.
If you can eat your pussy till scandal
comes back on next week.
What the fuck?
He's funny.
Dick.
Game strong.
I love that.
I love this one
world.
Somebody figured out a way to distribute
information through fucking pipes and a
numbers.
It's decoded back into letters,
ones and Zeros and this would have came
to Hashtag Dick Games.
Drawing.
You just be dealing with people with
problems all the time.
I don't think that's a good idea.
Just make your dicks off.
That's why.
Is that do it?
Yeah.
When someone tells you their problems,
I always feel like if you tell me your
problems,
you're making my Dick's off problems
make you dig south.
I've never.
Well,
I always felt like that when I was
dating,
you know,
it's like,
oh,
the girl,
she starts telling your problems,
you're like,
man,
you making them
ticks off.
Cheer Up,
boy.
Fuck.
What'd you think of him?
I loved.
Yeah.
I forgive him for dancing in the street
in the street with him and Mick Jagger,
Chicago.
I've been to forgive them.
I forgive them for arguably the most
confusing sexually,
at least to a young man.
I'm like,
what is happening?
What's going on with my.
What's that?
About why they freeze frame on that.
But is that you?
Did you do that Jamie?
Or is that the actual video?
That's how it ends.
That's unfortunate
when you go to whatever his boxing or
UFC,
the undercard no one's there.
They're all out getting drinks and
waiting for the thing that they don't
understand to happen.
That's at the end.
So
it's dead silent.
Bingo Hall Church.
Silence.
So you can heckle from the back row.
But Joe Rogan good as second row,
so it's absolutely quiet and we're in
their heckling.
Let me take your fucking him in the ass.
No,
no,
no.
Let me take it for granted because I
wasn't heckling at all because Douglas
doesn't do marijuana.
Joseph does marijuana.
Douglas does alcohol.
Joseph's freaking out because Douglas is
heckling them on your ticket and I'm
fucking laugh.
Or you're the one who brought me in.
So I'm kind of your responsibility.
Yeah,
try making him come.
That always knocks me out like a light.
I've been baking bread lately.
Holy Shit.
Sourdough bread.
Sourdough bread is very good for you.
It is.
Has Gluten though?
No,
I can't even ice skate.
Serious.
Can I scale it all?
Go.
Fuck.
I cannot escape.
Incredibly man.
I'm fucking again.
I'm waiting five on a good day.
You had them on the podcast.
Yeah.
No,
no.
You did a 100 percent sure he.
Nope,
he,
he came in with Eddie Wong.
But Roy Choi's,
a very famous chef,
one of the most famous famous chefs in
La Right now on episode was this type in
Roy.
Uh,
Joe Rogan.
I promise you because I watched it and I
was like.
So he was with Eddie?
Yeah.
No,
nope.
He was.
No,
I'm 100 percent certain.
Well,
I fight that Google's right.
Nope.
I a 100 percent certain.
Eddie Wong came in one time with the guy
that was in that movie of the interview.
I'm going to go to the mat on this one.
I'm looking at it right now and you're
wrong.
I'm really laid down on the Internet,
not backing me up with this boy toy
thing.
And I started.
It looks like I'm pretty sure he's
right.
He's not right.
He's right,
right?
Is that racist?
Racist.
It's just a gong.
Can we get away with a gong for anybody
gets mad at me?
David Cho or that you're thinking of?
No,
it's Roy Choi.
Burt.
Roy Choi was an episode of getting Doug
with high with Horacio Sands.
Uh,
Hiroshi CEO and me have often been
confused
way.
Yes.
Yes you are.
Are you serious?
You know it happens.
It's no big deal.
Burt wanted a minute.
Look at me.
Very competitive.
Getting Doug with high
effective dose is 20.
And what does he pop?
Pop to?
Two hundred and effective drawing over.
Fuck Cap.
He'll drive.
Well,
what?
I can't,
uh,
I can't.
I can smoke three,
I got the.
I could open up with three of these.
I can open up with 600 milligrams.
Just
no idea how insanely bed at night.
Like a baby.
I put that basket on.
I sleep like a fucking baby,
so it was just joey,
myself and the driver and we get in the
car.
There's no music on.
We're just talking and we just hit one
of those moments,
you know when you're on a highway at
night and you kind of hit that thing
where it's like you just.
Everyone stopped talking for a minute
and you're looking out the window and
you can feel like I'm just kind of
staring off.
No one's talking.
And then after like 15 seconds of
silence,
Julia goes,
that will tell you.
By the time I saw a guy cut open at the
tenderloin in 1979,
stomach split wide open.
And I was like,
what?
And I just see the driver's eyes widen.
And I was like,
no.
He goes,
yeah,
it's blood was brown because he was
bleeding for so long.
People just stepped over him and I saw
two guys stab each other.
Fucking street,
1980,
just over.
Nothing.
They just stab each other.
I didn't almost shit my pants,
but then I got used to it.
And then you just see the driver
like he can.
He can add in.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Oh Jesus.
Fucking Christ Jesus.
Fucking Christ.
Oh my God.
Jesus.
This is fucking tremendous.
Liquidity them again.
This is hard against broken
down like,
oh,
Jesus,
control.
Oh yeah,
but he doesn't know where he is.
He doesn't know where he is.
He doesn't know.
He doesn't know he is.
This is hard against fucking
cocksuckers.
I've been waiting for this bucket fight
for three fucking months.
This is what I'm talking about.
This is what the fucking problem is.
Okay?
You went to the body.
Every once in awhile,
you run into a fucking wall.
This Guy Diaz the fuck.
Are these people looking at shit.
You gotta kill this motherfucker.
Get over.
There's a new one.
50 five West.
Got Him now.
Where's the Gregor?
Now this catch Philadelphia.
You know motherfuckers,
Eddie Alvarez,
this is crazy.
I told you this is the fight in a bucket
year.
You fucking Momo totally sharp with your
bullshit.
Brock Lesnar and mark fucking art stuff
compared to this goddamn use.
God Damn Eddie Alvarez.
I told you I was excited when you called
me.
This is the fucking fighting cock
suckers.
Holy Shit.
Eddie Alvarez.
She says,
I gotta manage it.
Attack.
He looks fantastic.
That's what I'm fucking talking about.
So I say,
Joe,
I say to him,
Joey,
how'd you get into podcasts?
And his response,
you know Chael Sonnen,
he wanted me to jail.
It was always,
you know what is calls me Joe Rogan.
I'm mugged a hooker down in New Jersey
and senator Lee said her wig on fire.
It's like,
okay,
we got to.
There's two moving parts here.
First off,
that is,
I don't know how that answers my
question of how,
but now I need to know the story here.
So he ties it all together with.
He went on something,
just something.
He got an appearance.
He told the story of Mug and a hooker in
New Jersey and setting her wig on fire
and all of a sudden he blew up overnight
and he goes,
yeah.
I realized people like the stores.
I never knew that I had stories from the
part of the country I'm in and the
neighborhood I grew up in.
I thought everybody had these doors.
He's like,
chill center,
and I thought I'd tell you I mogul
hooker and lighter,
wiggling fire.
You Go,
yeah,
well I'm moved 10 hookers and let 10
wigs on fire.
I was like,
I didn't know I had stories.
Well in that way it's a swap meet in
Jersey.
They called,
what do they call the market?
Something like that.
I was a kid.
I used to go to where the use to do the
bicycles,
whatever those street car races and next
door to it.
They had what was called and you'd go
there and they had pretty much shit that
was stolen.
It was just a festival and they tries to
a table fee because everything was 50
percent off.
Even the sneakers I remember and then we
found that that the guy would go to the
fucking factory and jump over the fence
and take over
the sneakers,
no mistakes,
so the irregulars he,
they would take those and just sell them
at those markets.
Swap meets and then we find that we cut
into his action.
I just want it gone.
We,
we,
we cut into that action and the MANACA
action,
they're not going to.
Those tubes have been knocked.
Best Prank.
They would throw thousands of them out
with little things like the chemical was
off.
You start blinking too much,
like the chemical.
Then it was pepper spray,
pepper spray,
like people would spray and you can see
what happened.
It's not regular binocular.
What does that tear gas.
It was like the tickets.
The Spanish kid that was advertised and
we make them jump the fence and we'd
have thousands of tubes a and we'd sell
them for fifty cents a piece on Monday,
the sixth and seventh grade or virus,
but there was always three kids that
complain.
There was like the chemical imbalances
or
facebook friends with me from high
school and Pussy wouldn't get wet.
He used to call the dry hump,
the jersey,
they used to call her insurance.
Either
said she had some type of Vd,
so they called the lorry Jack.
She's got the Jack,
the Jack Jack.
Jack said he used to call her name and
Jack like that was like,
they just at this girl,
oh my God,
I got a score,
got coke,
she's got money.
I'm going to fuck her.
I'm excited.
We go back to a hotel.
We finally registered like $30.
They asked us through one of the Jacuzzi
in the room and shit.
It was one of those dirty hotels on
totally as you going to New York City.
We went in there,
we walked in and she goes,
rule number one,
you are not going to find me.
It's five in the morning.
That goes,
my fucking.
That goes this night and all of a sudden
she looks at me.
She goes,
well,
if you could guess the color of my
panties,
I fuck you.
I'm like,
okay,
read.
And she goes,
they're green,
but good enough.
We started snorting coke,
mass.
I mean it was filthy.
I woke up at five in the afternoon and
Doug flutie was thrown that quarterback
that down down 83.
I was waking up.
She was naked.
Rip Apart.
Fuck stretches.
Pain.
Now it's fucking is killer.
I mean,
music is so hard to pin down.
It's funny too because you know,
we had a bit of a.
We had a falling out recently and you
couldn't find a bigger stars will faint
to me.
I just listened to his record on the way
over here and it's a fucking
masterpiece,
but he also won't fucking talk to me
right now.
What happened?
Well,
here's the thing I don't even mind
talking about,
right?
I in an interview,
I said that he was,
and this is honestly what I believe,
I think he is.
And you're going to laugh when I say it,
but I swear this is what I fucking
believe.
I think he's a paid ass and
I'll just let that sink in for a second.
I think he's taken motherfuckers out
and they got this farm and they had
these horses.
There was over 100 hours of footage of
these people getting fucked by animals
and one guy,
they type it though.
There's a video of it.
You could watch it.
You want to see absolutely.
Look,
things go wrong all the time.
You can crawl up on the couch,
you can declare yourself a victim,
you can give up or you can recognize
that that's just part of life and wake
up the next day with a smile on your
face and continue to move forward and
just do your best.
I've told,
I've told the truth.
Uh,
I think it's really hard to do any
damage to somebody who's willing to tell
the truth regardless of the
consequences.
And then I admit mistakes.
I think mistakes have a way of.
So compounding themselves just because
people don't acknowledge those mistakes.
So given this pitch,
all I want to do is just get in the
polls that determines who is in the
presidential debates.
I think that if I'm in the presidential
debates,
I have an opportunity of actually
winning because of
this
package that you've allowed me to
present here today ago.
Thank you.
That's why the bad girls club show is
the greatest single and TV that.
Oh,
put a brick up a trailer for it.
If you're listening is going to be good.
They just get.
They get like we talked about this piece
of garbage and then they just fucking
make them drink and stuff.
I'm going a goddamn house for three for
three months and it's,
it's they have to go to the hospital for
the fights fights they've had this year
particularly.
It goes,
I'm over there trying to twerk in.
This bitch is like,
you know,
she tried to work next to me.
She was right in my workspace and it's
like bitch can't talk like me.
You shouldn't even be on the same level.
And then it's like having fights like
adults face.
He goes,
bitch,
because you ain't on my work level.
That's why I'm up in your face because
you ain't on my work level.
Tom Cruise.
He like a traveling king,
you know,
like he's got many,
many trailers like and like so like you
know,
you arrive in a situation,
you think,
right.
Era,
my prejudices about Tom Cruise,
all the things I've read,
all the things I've heard go prejudice.
Like we meet him,
he blasted me.
We've searched affability and charm that
they melt it away.
Ice cones.
Then the pure heat of the man sweetness.
You gave a lock on the sofa.
It was my birthday.
During that film I got a big basket full
of blight,
yoga related things and stuff like that.
At least sort of for,
for president.
You remember,
you know,
shake your hand.
Remembers your name,
sort of remembers details about aids.
I could bring.
You mentioned you're on a or something
in that conversation.
Next conversation.
You mentioned that on a one man his ass
for 10 hours really,
really late because of that fucking
monkey.
Actually it was playing up like he was
not working that day.
I went back,
went mandy's affidavit,
said when he'd been married,
Katie Holmes,
and it was that little ms dot Tom
Cruise.
Siri Cruz was,
they're all lined up.
I went there.
I was very,
very late and they'd like they to wheat
and goes,
oh,
well,
do you want to stay away?
I mean,
yeah,
yeah.
I will wait and I had to sat.
I'm sat with you now.
Joe Opposite Tom Cruise and Katie Holmes
and the little dial in one.
I was fucking eating spaghetti and it's
as a complicated thing to eat.
He's long isn't it?
The lady and the tramp shoving that shit
in and then the next course I think was
the signer,
which was weird because that's to pass
the courses.
Then I think there was like sort of
cupcakes and stuff involved
all the way through.
It just sat opposite.
Tom Cruise talking about communism,
which I brought up as a topic,
which in retrospect was a mistake.
Why?
Well,
because don't bring up communism or let
me ask you this.
I've got to pop it in the spring.
Bottled water.
I just wanted to dig out Bro.
Guess how much.
Not Small enough for that.
Don't piss all over my floor in here.
Yeah,
you can do it in there.
Just just corn hole that we have to go
soon anyway because I to get something.
Me Put the Cameron Nearest Dick or were
the
first folks.
That's the first time anybody's peed on
the pocket.
Don't take a photo of his dick.
It's blocked by the cup.
If you guys taking a photo of your dick,
Bro,
that's a full Kombucha.
Definitely don't drink that.
You're going to piss in the pickles too,
bro.
How'd you cut off stream for sure.
You're dribbling on my carpet?
No,
I fully,
fully,
fully this cock.
Jamie pulled up to the fucking
definition.
Is this an urban dictionary?
This is a better definition,
I think that no one you gave.
Oh,
how dare you.
Hey,
demasculated millennial,
liberal male who often speaks of white
privilege and modern feminism,
blames white men for all of the world's
problems.
The new definition or.
I like this though.
There goes chat again with the megaphone
telling everyone that he's a Vegan.
What a cook.
Okay.
I like that.
Did you.
Do you
stay in any way in touch with those kids
from back in the day from the kids that
bullied you?
Did you ever.
It was actually funny after the ultimate
fighter,
um,
I got invited out by one of the guys,
and uh,
just because I think a couple of people
will just,
yeah,
saw one of the guys who was one of the
main guys and he's like,
Hey,
I'm walking around downtown Fort Worth
and said,
why don't we go out here,
whatever.
I'm like,
all right,
I'll go.
And.
Well,
he had actually brought me into a Sushi
restaurant in all around the table was
most of the people that were not most is
probably only like eight or 10 people,
but they were some of the main kids that
were at that party when I dressed up and
everything.
Man,
if you,
if we'd have known you were a fighter or
could've kicked their butts and we
wouldn't have done that to you.
And I'm just like,
it's.
So I told him I was going to the
bathroom just left.
Um,
I think that's the only time I've ever
done anything like that,
but I'm just like,
I can't,
I can't be around these guys.
And I don't think we should talk about
trump for a long time,
but.
But that's,
he's got a lot of charisma.
Say what you want to love the guy.
He's got a ton of charisma and that's
weird.
Kind of charisma.
Yeah.
He's got like this mean guy charisma.
You want him to like you.
So you say things like you don't even
believe.
Yeah.
Because you want him to like think that
you're on his side so we won't come
after you.
Yeah.
That's a bully charisma.
That's absolutely right.
But it's charisma nonetheless.
That's the.
And that's the thing about stars and
movie stars and stuff like that.
It's like you're watching this guy,
you watch denzel Washington waiting for
him to snap.
He never does.
But your weight,
you can tell he's Gunna,
he just doesn't.
It's like Robert Downey Jr.
I feel like with robert downey jr.
You're watchIng a guy not do cocaine.
Yeah.
He wants to do everything in him,
wants to do cocaine.
So you're watching a guy not actively,
not do cocaine from second to second.
That's such a good analysis.
Yeah.
That you're just trying.
You're just watching this guy,
this thing,
this car accident that never happens.
I know somebody to talk to a cop and
they said that when he started working
and then 11 years later.
Oh yeah.
Going into those areas where these
things always happen and after years and
years it just,
it just wears on you for sure.
Know from the aiR.
This is me growing up in situations,
you know what I mean?
I wouldn't want to go back.
I barely go back there,
you know,
so.
But it Do give you nerves.
You'll nerves heightened in naturally
kicks.
Oh,
100 percent,
you know,
and like,
yeah,
some people can't handle those nerves.
You learn how to breathe quietly.
You don't know like somebody,
you could walk down the street and
somebody could pull a pistol out on
those things though.
I've been driving down the street with
my ex lady and she was talking and I was
like,
get down because I saw a guy draw on a
corner and shoot across the street at
another guy that's the gun went up.
We drove under the,
the,
the fire.
Right.
But it was long,
it was long.
Oh my god.
And then they went up,
we went under the second shot off and I
drove and I was like,
man,
that was crazy.
Like I'm that guy.
She laid it out,
we made that was crazy.
And she was like,
you didn't call the police.
And I was like,
well,
what is he like to tell what happened?
And I was like,
I don't want to be.
And that's how crazy it is that you
don't even want to be involved because
you got to go to the cops and I end up
calling the police and um,
things like he described the victim.
I was like,
white t shirt,
blue Jeans,
that's all I said.
And that it was like,
was he black?
And it was just a long pause.
It was a long poles and they like sarah
is he black?
And I was like,
man,
you know,
that nick was black
men do that all.
I have several of those in my own,
not nuclear family but my family of
procreation.
So might fruit.
I won't saY who,
but brutal.
Right.
And,
and here's another thing that you never
admit that you're wrong,
right,
because admitting that you're wrong
makes you lose face.
And that's such a detrimental dynamic to
have,
right?
I mean,
you know,
I might come home at night and um,
I've had a tough day and I might respond
correctly to my dog.
I actually will go back and then hug my
dog because I have enough self awareness
to realize that I didn't give her enough
attention.
Right?
So I have enough humilitY to,
nevermind,
you know,
another human.
My dog is just as important to me.
And if I responded curtly,
I will sort of apologized to Her.
Yet I've got family members,
uh,
again,
this is not my family of my wife or
kids,
but the family that I was born into that
have never apologized about anything
because they come from a cultural
landscape where to apologize to your
child,
to somebody younger is to lose face at
parent is always right.
And I mean that might work when you're
too,
but when you're both now adults,
I think you sort of have to get out of
that and realized that we all make
mistakes and we all have to own up to
them.
Like I want to see me get beat the fuck
up.
Just jamie.
Jamie shown a video of me about to get
my ass kicked by nick diaz
are you get destroyed really fast.
I would imagine if the game is
realistic,
fill it up and I get fucked up.
People want to say it.
But they might have used the ceo's
secret character.
They might have.
You got some bullshit skills.
Might have you juiced up.
I got it.
Doesn't matter.
I got some bullshit with.
Let's hear mike because you know I'm
super casual fan.
So my commentary.
No.
Rather with the leg kick.
I've never heard this before.
Oh.
Oh,
we're all good with the leg kicks.
Rogan get kicked in the face.
Oh good.
With the kicks.
Diaz is back it up.
Rogan missed.
oh really?
Kicked in the chest.
Tattoos.
Accurate.
Look at that.
And a lot of scientology training in
terms of what it imparts to people is a
quality of being,
direct,
being assertive,
being confident,
being in charge,
and being okay with sort of dominating
the situations that you're in.
It'S one of the reasons that I think it
appeals a lot to act as because it,
it,
it works,
I think for people who have any sort of
insecurity or who are going into
situations of uncertainty and it allows
you to almost reprogrammed your circuits
in some way and be okay about using
assertive body language and speech and
it also imparts a sense that you have
all the truett's necessary to save
humanity from itself.
Not just humanity on earth,
but throughout time and space,
and it is your obligation to ensure that
those truths are saved,
saved for posterity,
and communicated as widely as possible
in a totally unadulterated fashion
because any adulteration of the message
means that not only do they not work,
they become toxic and dangerous.
Is it good?
Good.
I like it.
Let me try something that give it a go.
What do you do with it?
Take a little bump.
Put it under your lip bump.
Little pinch cocaine style bump.
Now we've never done that either.
I'd go less and less asked.
Plenty for you.
Is that too much?
that's good.
Okay.
Where do you put it?
Anywhere you put any love you want,
it's start to burn a little cranky.
Cancer or immediately?
I don't think so.
I mean now you shouldn't.
I get messages every day from people
that lost 100 pounds.
Right?
Feeling healthy.
The problem is we're dealing with
propaganda and you can do one or two
things.
You could either just say,
well,
you know,
this is this.
I think I swallowed all that tobacco.
Yeah.
It's all gone.
I was wondering why I'm so hard.
You got to to on it.
It's gone.
I have it swallowed up.
I had a boy.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Alright.
Julian,
drink and swat,
right?
Something like that.
Like chris brown,
like fuck is under age cousin and then
piss on somebody.
No,
those are kelly.
You could fit like three different black
people.
I don't know who.
Fuck their cousin kelly was peeing on
people.
Didn't.
He used to put this lately and molest
them.
No,
that's the other guy.
That's bill cosby.
Oh,
got it.
Jesus christ and that crazy.
Like,
what the fuck man,
I can't tell black people are just
realized that you confused r kelly and
chris brown.
Is That bad when they.
They're off by like
15,
20 years.
What if one of them is our age?
Our kelly is,
is,
is he's 49.
And when did he play basketball?
He didn't play basketball.
He's a singer,
a singer.
Got it.
He sets up like the really cheesy
anchors to ask him stupid questions
like,
did you?
Oh,
you had someone to do the bird is fat
thing.
That was the best one because you know,
if you ever.
Sometimes when you go,
hey,
um,
you know,
asked me about farts or something,
they'll be like,
like,
so they,
they know not to,
they,
they check themselves on asking
something provocative or that's not 100
percent pg.
So I didn't know how it go,
but I go,
oh,
ask me my birth.
So fat and the lady goes,
okay.
And then.
So we just are in the middle of this
interview
and she goes,
white bird,
so fat and I was like,
a good question and I'm like,
I just rolled with it,
you know,
and then it grew.
And then a hot dog eating champion,
a guY that was in scotland,
she placed tinny place.
Yeah.
He's like one of The,
he was like a super competitive eater,
like a kobiashi dude.
This guy was assigned.
You play the audio on this.
It's incredible
life changing stuff.
Uh,
um,
dropped about 100 pounds in eight
months.
He dropped 100 pounds my cheat day for
the year,
but prepping just this amazing water
drive.
Two giant inspirations.
First my wife second anniversary today.
So I want to say hi to her.
And um,
there's a comedian I love.
He's a big,
giant fat guy just like me,
bert chrysler,
he's still way bigger than I am.
MaYbe this fire him now explain that.
Why do you think they did that?
Do you think they did that?
Because if they overturn your case,
if they can somehow or another because
they don't want to check.
But is that it or is that discrediting
you in like that was a gigantic hit
movie.
But if they decide,
if they can discredit you,
it makes that movie still valuable.
Not only that,
it stops me from running for president
donut.
If they can discredit me.
Do you want to run for president?
I thought about it.
Even living in Mexico from Mexico would
have had to forsake of that.
That's why I didn't do it.
The,
no,
the uh,
the reason why you didn't run for
president because you would have to have
forsaken live in New Mexico.
Now I might fucking when I know.
I figured I could have one.
No.
The libertarians contacted me twice to
come to their convention.
They wanted to nominate jesse.
Come back to America.
Com.
Ken and I chose not to do it because I
was up for the campaigning.
I was up to taking on,
taking on the damage and repubs.
But at this point,
at age 65,
I wash up to do the job for four years
where I'd have to end my lifestyle and
Mexico because people don't realize when
you take,
when you get one of them jobs like
president or governor,
your freedom leaves that day.
You don't have freedom.
We're pressured in to get this money.
Then why aren't we making fucking more?
Why eric?
Am I a bartender in addition to a
paleontologist in addition to somebody
that's on tv,
if I'm making all this big pharma or big
paleo fucking money,
if I'm such a shill.
Okay.
Yeah.
Is that why I'm a month behind on my car
payment right now?
Is that why I'm trying to scrape
together rent?
Fuck.
You can aggressive.
Very aggressive.
These guys.
Prestige or fame and attention.
There's the bandwagon effect and crowd
behavior.
And then there are people and entities.
Wait,
but wait,
wait,
wait.
The bandwagon effect and the and crowd
behavior like flat earth bullshit.
Okay.
We're only seven minutes and 53 seconds
into a 29 minute video.
Fuck.
But I have a feeling.
I mean,
I don't,
I don't know for sure,
but my guess would be that if you wanted
to find people who said,
yeah,
trump grabbed my pussy,
it wouldn't be that fucking hard.
It's not like you're looking for bigfoot
pretty easy to have them be my guess.
Right.
But so,
so it wasn't like a hard thing to do.
It's a bread crumb trail.
It very simple,
very easy.
And so it's like when you realize like
that,
then you start feeling this weird
compassion for him and you're like,
my god.
Even with all his like maliciousness and
like weird pervasiveness and stuff.
Ultimately he,
they,
he's like a fucking bowl.
They got put into a god damn ring with a
matador.
He's been doing this kind of bull
fighting for like 30 fucking years for
better or for worse.
And he's,
we're watching what we saw last night I
guess.
And what's interesting about it,
a big part of what's interesting about
it is he came really close to women.
I mean he's still in the neighborhood of
winning plus or minus 11 points or would
that means is between now and how many
days do we have until the election is 21
days.
Listen man,
lot of crazy shit can happen in 21 days
to shift people's opinions,
but apparently again from all those
stats now look man,
I tried to get.
I tried to say any of that stuff because
you don't even know if it's true.
They're all just talking on tv and they
brainwash and all of us to let us think
that they know who the is voting.
I don't know if she knows how to be just
herself.
That's a good point.
I mean I.
My problem with hillary is,
is purely an operational one.
I know that if I had handled,
I mean even in the conservative way,
if you look at what she did with the
email server and her colleagues or
cohorts did and you say,
okay,
it's,
you know,
in a conservative way.
I'm looking at at how bad it was.
If I had done that,
I would have been sent to prison and I
know because we had various counter
intelligence operations and alto,
you're trying to find the lake,
you're trying to find the problem and
you watch people get banged up for less
egregious acts and then what she's been
involved in.
So my problem with hillary is looking at
one set of rules for everybody.
The system is,
is broken in that respect,
but given the choices,
you know,
and when you have a choice between
someone who is for all her flaws,
been in the game for long enough to be
really well informed and capable of
compromise and capable of,
uh,
not just,
just
breaking
the entire machine and you have someone
who's just,
he could just kind of stepped off the
set of his reality tv show and then he
lied about everything and uh,
an elbowed his way onto your television
set and never left because,
you know,
cnn couldn't figure out how to give the
mic to someone else.
Um,
it's,
uh,
it's amazing.
Well,
he's a product of attention because they
realize that there's a heated race
right?
The heated race,
this guy was really famous and in a
heated race,
this guy would say some crazy stuff and
so they would tune into them so
everybody had to do an intro.
So because of him saying crazy stuff,
he accelerated the amount they were
talking about them.
so they're constantly talking about him
and barely talking about other people
and.
But he's created a warm hOle in our
political process now where there's
nothing so crazy that could disqualify
him among the people who liked him to so
he can just keep it just like nuclear
bombs of craziness that the press can't
ignore that the every time they think,
okay,
this is the crazy thing.
He said it's Going to harm his
candidacy,
so let's shine a light on it.
It just helps him,
you know,
he could just,
he could,
he could get on twitter right now and
say,
you know who I'd like to fuck,
I'd like to fuck nikki minaj and,
and it would work for him.
It was work for them.
You would see or use a tweet storm of a
billion people who say,
I'd like to fuck nikki minaj to go get
her,
and it's insanity.
That's where we are.
When people said that was a trump
supporter,
what they meant was they may have only
seen part of what I was talking about.
I was writing about his skill as a
persuader and what I mean is that I
noticed in him the skills that I've
developed over decades for persuasion,
but at a higher level than I've ever
seen.
Meaning that he is the most persuasive
living human I've ever experienced.
yeah.
It looks like trump kind of kicked her
ass to.
It's pretty fucking weird.
Let's.
It's two 60,
four to 2:15 right now.
Is this phil?
We are an old trump.
This weird.
I feel like down because won
the crowd one weird on us.
Responsible
such a beautiful night.
That was probably the most fun I've ever
had on a podcast.
I keep.
I've said that before because I had
some.
We've had some fun ones together.
Oh yeah,
but that one might have topped it off.
I don't think I've ever laughed any
harder,
like burr had me laughing.
Harder than.
I mean,
just as hard as you can.
Laugh
at the end of it at 1:30 in the morning,
trump tweets him at 1:30 in the morning.
Little jon stewart is a pussy
and would be hopeless in a debate with
me.
I wouldn't even do that.
I'm going to.
I'll be the dude.
That means he was walking around talking
to himself.
They do brief dumb for the next
presidential thing and he goes,
all right,
I will see you later.
And he closed the door.
He's walking around his gold toed socks
hotel room.
I could go up and say,
I'm a fucking asshole.
Let me stop.
He had probably some woman there,
guy Donald Trump.
Go on the internet.
Want this shit.
I had taken this shit.
Fucking liberal media fucking tweaking
this thing out.
There
it all down.
I think we just violated the new laws.
This is like that hillary commercial
where they had the little kids watching
politics.
Bullshit.
Little kids.
Don't watch politics.
There you go.
It's all about the future.
Comfortable with this.
You're not comfortable with lower doing
trump.
Trump's winning New Hampshire.
Hillary's winning Virginia really?
And as a little kid here,
he decided it was good idea.
I think that's totally illegal,
right?
Like you didn't have a fucking baby
while people are talking about eating
fake pussies.
That was before I didn't,
but if the kid was in the club,
we shut up.
Sure.
By the way,
through the elc spend.
Delicious.
Thank you.
I made this american chopped suey with
it and my wife gave a fucking bad review
before anybody even tasted it and
everybody just said,
fuck it.
Like she goes,
it looks like hamburger helper.
I've been shouting it for like four
days.
I got a respect for that fucking else
that you shot.
It's like,
I'm eating all this shit.
I don't care if it's fucking bed.
Does it make you more aggressive?
what?
No,
joe,
you fucking lunatic.
Somebody gets in my face.
That might cost me to get more.
Lunatic.
Ate a little bit of protein.
You had to beat the fuck out of people
for like three decades before you could
like chill.
Smoke a little weed,
put on your little rascals hat and just
fucking
chill out.
Can
I say that?
Have you heard that study about like,
you know how they tried to figure
out like if everybody.
They always say liKe anybody can be
president of the United States,
right?
Like anybody,
everybody in America has the same
opportunities,
but what they've found is that some
people have one opportunity and other
people have many opportunities and
that's the difference.
So are you saying the world is unfair?
No,
but you were saying
it would have been a mark.
Like is a weT dream.
I'd molesters most of.
I remember watching the kid get molested
one time.
Oh no.
Not,
not like molested,
but like it was definitely an assault.
Boom.
And we're live.
Let's go check champ.
Let's go jam.
If you said anything else other than
let's go champions.
The first thing you said in the podcast
will be a giant.
We had to start it off.
Right?
The in the candidate,
by the way.
Pleasure meeting you finally.
Youtube as well,
champ.
Let's go champ.
I appreciate this.
So much positivity is happening right
now,
champ.
All around the world,
people saying,
let's go champ.
Yeah,
I couldn't imagine a champ.
I was.
I'm wanting to commit suicide and now
I'm walking.
Everywhere I go,
people are going to
miss this.
This is a sign that I'm back.
You're back.
I'm back chat.
Let's go chat.
Thank you everybody.
That was beautiful that you can share.
So I didn't expect any support from my,
from my colleagues and.
And it isn't that I don't care if I got
it,
but it's,
it's in some sense it's irrelevant.
It's irrelevant to me because my goal
was.
I'm not saying those god damn pronouns
and the reason I'm not saying them is
because they're made up by left wing
ideologues and I don't like left wing
ideology ideology period.
And I know where corruption of speech
leads and I'm not goIng there.
So let's just talk about what happened.
You
tested positive for some
estrogen inhibitors as blockers
yesterday,
and blockers that a lot of people
associate with people who take steroids.
We're talking about john.
This whole thing is going out with john
based on a test that took place on June
16th.
The reason that relevant when I went
through my thing,
I was know he tested positive for
semester.
Jim blockers,
those don't really have anything to do
with anything.
They don't help you that they're silly.
I think you might've just revealed
something.
He tested positive for two estrogen.
Yeah,
but no one else knew that.
There you go.
I'm revealing broke personal
information.
That's what we're doing here though.
Right?
Wow.
But thIs is like,
this is like the only way that anybody
could find that out is if you talked
about it.
Boom.
It's out there.
Right.
And that we're doing here,
aren't we?
Creating some news.
It's a big news day basically.
What did you take?
So took a.
I took
an off offbrand cialis pill off brand.
It was,
it wasn't actual cialis,
but it was described to me as being a
cialis and so I thought it was a cialis
and I.
I just took it and jlp son and leaked
the information during my last podcast.
So It's out of it's shell has leaked out
information.
It could be.
Is it what he said to me out there?
They had no,
nothing.
I didn't hear anybody talking about,
honestly,
I'm in a weird position because I don't
think you're supposed to.
I don't think he supposed to.
Anybody's supposed to be talking about
the medical results until like it gets
released.
I don't know how it works.
I really don't.
I'm going to plead ignorance,
right?
I'll plead ignorance all day.
He might own name.
I think he probably took boner pills
because that's.
They have all that shit in them.
You know,
like they have potent pills,
have steroids in them always hitting.
Right.
Because I just found that at joe's gas
station over here,
it has like the best I've never seen
these right on is known for his love of
the boner pill.
He means what you would call a boner
pill contour.
He's actually read blogs about boner
pills and directed me to reviews of
boner pills.
Terrified.
But I mean these things have steroids in
them.
They have a bunch of stuff and if you
party wasn't the last thing he got
busted for cocaine or something.
If you bus,
if you do cocaine,
lot of guys take these because you can
get hard off of having cocaine and so if
he takes boner pills then he's going to
be tempered a little too much.
Speculation for respect.
No,
I didn't think I got lucky.
I thought that you failed drug tests
when you're doing sketchy shit.
Right?
But didn't you think there might be some
sketchy shit and some chinese?
No.
Station rhino.
Dick pill.
I,
um,
what you know about the rhinos.
My friend ryan,
my friend brian called it,
he was on the,
on the podcast.
He said,
you know,
john likes to party.
I Bet he took one of them dick pills.
um,
no.
Um,
that's funny you called it.
Yeah.
Well he,
he was,
he was on.